-Good evening.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well
tonight.
And now we're going
to get to the news.
Judge Ketanji Brown Jackson
today became the first
Black woman to be confirmed
to the Supreme Court,
in case you're wondering
why the flag over the Fox News
building is at half staff.
[ Laughter ]
That's right,
Judge Ketanji Brown Jackson
today became the first
Black woman to be confirmed
to the Supreme Court.
And I can't believe
I have to say this --
Brett, that champagne
was for everyone.
[ Laughter ]
In a speech
at a union conference,
President Biden joked that
he had forgotten the name
of former President Trump
and said,
"That last guy, what was
his name, anyway?
He never showed up
in the inauguration.
Though, to be fair, it's not
like we showed up to his."
[ Laughter ]
Former President Trump yesterday
officially endorsed
Georgia Congresswoman
Marjorie Taylor Greene
for re-election and said she is
"a warrior who doesn't back down
and doesn't give up."
Basically, all the same reasons
she's banned from Target.
[ Laughter ]
NBC News staffers
are reportedly worried
that the company's decision
to hire
White House Press Secretary
Jen Psaki
to host a show on MSNBC could
taint the network's credibility.
Meanwhile, Fox News
is almost entirely taints.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelenskyy
is the world's most popular
leader among Americans.
But, remember, Volodymyr,
two weeks ago,
Will Smith was our most popular
movie star.
[ Laughter ]
Pinterest announced yesterday
that it will prohibit users
from sharing climate
misinformation on the platform,
forcing them to move to Etsy.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
NASA announced this week
that an asteroid the size
of a small house flew by Earth.
And this is crazy --
It got three offers on Zillow.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody!